everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
get to work on this main website that
we've been working on with react and we
pull the data from the WordPress API
we're using a graph QL the WP graph QL
plug-in we're going to pull it in to our
react site using Apollo and we're gonna
make some components and we need to set
up some custom routes so we are using
next js' so they have some routing built
in but we need a little bit more
functionality which is cool because
they've built next in such a way that
it's really easy to add additional
routing features if you need to and we
always end up needing to I don't know I
don't remember project where we didn't
need to do that all right
hey everyone I see some of you in the
live chat now let's see oh one question
before we start I've been thinking about
it's 9:00 and we're just this no it's
not 9:00 a.m. where I'm at it's 12:00
noon so 12:00 p.m. where I am so I'm in
the United States like East Coast time
so Eastern Time
so anyway I have a question I think I
brought this up a while ago in the
stream but I've been thinking about
doing again maybe like I'm gonna put
some info somewhere I don't know if will
be on my website or wherever I'll put it
but it's basically just gonna have some
referral codes for products that I use
are ways to donate I just wanted to
throw it out there to see do you all
think this is an OK thing to do or is
this like in bad taste does it seem like
I just don't want to I'm doing this
stuff you know for free like I want to
help you out and you all already helped
me out a lot so I don't want to seem
like I'm begging for donations or
anything like that
and it's like with the referral
a lot of them you know whoever uses it
will get some something as well as me so
I mean let me just show you I guess what
I have and you let me know if it seems
in bad taste or if it'd be okay I'll
make it a bit bigger so like this is
what I'm thinking
so like coinbase is where I do my like
crypto training and stuff so you get ten
bucks on on coinbase these are my
wallets for the different coins that I
have I get clothes for trunk club so I
was going to put the link there you get
I don't remember what you get on trunk
club I haven't used in a while like
digitalocean you'll get a $10 credit if
you use that and I think I get ten
there's I can't remember what I get
SiteGround I have some sites there as
well Trello I think you get like free
months of Trello
like paid plan so anyway these are all
the ones I could just think of they're
probably probably might might be able to
do more but anyway let me know in the
live chat which you think if you're
watching this later let me know in the
in the comments because I don't I don't
want to do anything that would get like
hurt this dream so I'm not planning on
getting rich off of this I was just you
know throwing it out there
let's see all right it looks like
alright looks like at least a few you
think that that's cool to do so maybe
y'all it's not a high priority right now
but I'll get that up somewhere someone
asks Larry asked what my website is it's
Jesse Michael calm but I haven't updated
it in like five years
so now I take that back I did do a
slight content update like three years
ago or two and a half years
but the site was actually built at least
five years so it needs updated I just
haven't decided what direction I want to
go with it should it be a straight
portfolio should it be a blog I don't
know but that probably would be a good
place to put stuff like this I can maybe
put it somewhere in my youtube channel
as well I'm definitely not going to put
it anywhere in the free code camp
channel because I want you know
donations or anything to go to free code
camp and not to me on that channel so
anyway thank you all for forgiving me
feedback on that I appreciate it
okay Sergio does have an important
question I'm gonna just now before you
started Sergio says I'm following
project 5 which is this project
day 3 so so far this project is with
material react material UI and next or
Gatsby so we ended up going with next
I know early on in the project I had
said I thought it would be cool to
develop both with Gatsby and material UI
and then compare I just I still think it
would be cool to do that but we need to
get the site launched in time and I
think I'm I'm gonna need all the time I
can get so we decided not to do that
I still left the branch open for Gatsby
in case anybody loves Gatsby and really
wanted to try to build some stuff out
and Gatsby that's that's still an option
and I'll still show it on the stream if
somebody really wanted to but we ended
up going with with next okay okay
Nicki has a good point it says that that
stuff meaning the referral codes and
things are fine as long as you don't
start off every video with a buy my
stuff [ __ ] oh yeah I definitely won't
I'll probably like if I do it I'll just
mention it one time say like hey I did
this here it is and I won't talk about
it again
it on free code camp I will talk about
it maybe I'll talk about it on my
channel too so we'll see but yeah I
definitely don't want to start off with
that I think that I don't know it's just
like I don't have a problem when other
people do it I guess you know you got it
you know people are given their time to
make videos so why why not you know be
compensated for it but I just kind of
don't want it to be I don't know like
that for me see
hello Christian is asking what does this
been a subscriber for a while but I
don't know what this life thing is all
right so I'm at work and I am a
front-end developer and I'm working on a
real project that I have to do for work
so whatever I need to do in a particular
day I just share you know an hour or two
of my work and then I answer any
questions along the way that you might
have so and then we collaborate so you
all have a chance to add code if you'd
like and yes so that's pretty much what
the stream is I was just kind of hoping
that people would see what my day-to-day
like life is like as a developer and see
me make mistakes and try to recover from
that so anyway so stick around for a
little bit we're about to start some
coding now just to kind of see you know
how we do this I usually hold off and do
the questions answer questions towards
the end but if you don't if you can't
stick around right now
then you know maybe you can always watch
the recording later but if you do watch
it live it's cool because you can
actually ask questions and comment and
kind of interact with everyone in the
lab chatting with me all right
Louie's again says think about creating
a udemy course yeah you know what I I'm
still thinking about doing that I just I
don't have a lot of time right now maybe
after we get this site launched then I
can have a little bit of time for that
coding and caffeine is here hey I got
that covered I got my G fuel and I have
a half of a mug of lukewarm coffee that
is a day old so I got all the caffeine I
need all right let's get started let me
show you let's get the site up here I
have n drop running I never turned it
off from yesterday
so let me paste that in the live chat
here for you all if you click on this
link that I just put in a lot of chat
that'll take you to the website that's
running locally on my machine and you
can inspect any dev tools and you
navigate to different pages whatever you
want and I was migrating a lot of stuff
over so just to give you a heads up I've
added a few more custom post types so we
have custom post types now on the
WordPress installation for directories
so I'm sorry departments so faculty
departments we have ones for majors
which we've had the majors in there for
a while
but I can't remember if we had it on if
I did it on the stream and we have a
custom post type for Human Resources
content and also for campus security
content so I brought over i've migrated
all the content for departments all the
content for majors and some content for
Human Resources I don't think I found it
all in the database and I just saw we
have a request to share this Pomodoro
timer I'm gonna start this up now so I
break up everything in a 25-minute
chunks and then we take a break for five
minutes do some question and answer and
then go back and do another 25 minutes
and see
all right so this is the site if you
remember I've decided that I think we
ought to focus on the mobile view first
so we're gonna be in this mobile view
most of the time and then we'll expand a
double-check and make sure things look
all right when we have a a wider screen
and let's go to the code now so what we
need to do is get pull in some of that
new data that I migrated from our sequel
server database over to the my sequel
database and we're gonna pull that out
with graph QL and we need to bring it
over so the first thing we need then is
well we need a component to bring the
data into but we also need a query a
graph QL query so let's do that now I've
we have so we just did this one the last
time we were messing around with graph
queue oh we made this component we made
a query for it so this is going to be an
ideal component for us to copy we didn't
do a lot of custom things with it
so this will be kind of our template
we're gonna copy this and then we'll
paste will make another page so this is
the the pages folder in and next
normally anything in this folder
automatically becomes a route so if I
went to like slash faculty J s it would
take me to a page it'd take me through
this this faculty painter and it would
treat the the component as like the root
page there but you'll see in a minute
we're gonna do some custom routing and
we'll have to work on that too to get
everything to work right so we do have a
little bit different stuff going on here
so first things first let's make this
component I'm using Visual Studio code
here in case the ones anyone is
wondering and let's see I have the seti
theme running why can't I find this
because it's not there I'm just trying
to make a new file there we are
Department jas there we are
and now let's change the name here yes
well let's actually grab this right up
here and all right and I don't want this
capitalization here so I'm going to get
rid of that right now
and I'm gonna get rid of it here all
right so we have this ready and what
it'll give us is the content so let me
explain I guess I'll explain this
briefly since we have it up here we
there's a lot of other stuff that kind
of went into this so I'm not going to go
over every piece of it if you want to
know more about that you can look at the
code it's available on our github repo
the links in the description you can
watch previous episodes previous streams
if you want to figure out kind of more
of how we set this up we didn't set up
everything on the stream but I do
believe we went over everything on the
stream so basically when a user goes to
a certain route which we will set up so
it'll be like departments slash English
right for let's say we go to the English
department page so you type in
Franciscan dot edu slash departments
slash English and what will happen first
is the router
we'll pass the ID which in this case
would be the slug English we'll pass it
to our component right so we have ID
passed and the idea is then getting it
passed through our query which we're
going to write in a minute that query
based on the ID is going to ask for that
specific information we need to render
this page from our WP graph QL plug-in
that we have running with WordPress and
our my sequel database we're gonna get
the data back it's going to get rendered
potentially server-side could possibly
also render client-side that's what time
this get initial props function allows
that to happen then our data is going to
be available to us through props right
so we've already we have this prop set
here for data so we don't need to use it
down here but basically we go this props
data depts edges and edges eternal race
we need to get the first element in the
array node and then content that gives
us our content that lives in the my
sequel database right so we pulled all
that in and then it will render that
specific content for the English
department because that's the route we
went to so that's how it's all going to
happen we have one part of this done we
need two other parts for this to really
work so let's set up our query and then
let's set up our route and it should
work so we can take go to our queries
where do I have these that let me shrink
some of these folders here so we can see
what we're dealing with components live
queries good all right so we're gonna
make a new file and we're gonna call
this
we're gonna also call this department
Dutch ass and let's take what we had in
major and let's copy it go back to the
department and paste it alright so this
is what a graph QL query looks like you
can do a lot of other things with
graphical queries but this is what we
need to do for this one so let's change
the name here so we need department so
we have this department query we're
exporting this is a constant right and
then we imported our component as we saw
earlier and that's why we can use it in
the component but it's gonna grab that
that string so we're passing in what we
have here is as name we're passing in
that ID that that slug if you want to
use the term that WordPress uses for
their posts we're passing that in so
it's going to look in departments where
the name is equal to in our example case
we're gonna say English so where the
name is English so what we'll have in
our database is there's only going to be
one depart piece of data that has
Department or has the slug of English
okay so we're gonna make sure it's
always just one and then within that we
got to go down some some levels that's
just the way the data is set up but then
we want to get the ID of that post we
want to get the title the slug and the
content there are other things we could
get as well but we don't we don't need
it we don't need to display that on on
this page so if you want to go to the
repo you can check out our other queries
sometimes we're getting other things if
you just want to see some some different
examples they're there but for now this
is all we need and you see we actually
aren't even using these yet but I was
pulling them in because I anticipated
potentially needing them at some point
if we get closer to the site launch or
even after we launch and we find that we
don't need this
we can always get rid of these and then
we'll just save a little bit of data
coming in so let me save that so we have
two of our three parts done now we have
our component we have our query now
let's go to our server and let's put
this route in so we have our server Jas
file and you can see how we did this
with major right so we're doing server
get major and then we have this ID here
right and that's kind of the variable
part and then we're making sure that the
component that gets rendered is major
right so it matches up in this case
sometimes we have difference so in this
case our URL is going to be contact but
we're actually sending it to the
directory component so you can't name
your components in your route something
entirely different and still direct it
to the right place generally though I'm
trying to keep things the same so I had
some other things here I think that were
tests okay yeah so we're gonna need to
let's grab this one and I need I need to
split this up a bit make some comments
majors
unfortunately our router is going to get
huge we need to try to keep the URLs
intact from the old the current site and
the new site that we're building so
that's that's kind of proving a little
bit difficult that's why our router is
going to be a bit of a mess unless we
can figure out some other solution to
this but right now some of the content
is just we're just going to manually
have to make these routes alright so let
me go with Department Department and
then ID is going to go to Department and
I what I actually want to is I want
another route so I'm just gonna put it
in here right now although we're not
gonna do anything with it yet I want if
we have department with nothing at the
end I want that to go to let's call it
departments
the apartment list so we're gonna have
to make that component basically I want
Department to have a list of all the
departments and then you can click on
that so that's how we're going to do
that I'm pretty sure that'll work I have
done it before but I haven't looked at
the code for it for a few months all
right so now when a user goes to in our
case localhost 3002 or something maybe
we run in 3,000 locals 3,000 and then
department and in our case we were gonna
say English
it'll route that send that I dated
apartment grab the data that it needs
and then render it alright make sure
that saved whoops there we are
alright so that saves you have a query
we have a component let's try it out
there's actually one more thing I need
to do I imported a data but
unfortunately we need to manually go in
and change the slugs to make this work
there's really no way around that so I
think I'm gonna have one of my
colleagues go in and do this or a
student worker do it because it's
certainly something I could do but
there's other things that only I can do
so it's better if I use my time for that
and this is something that really anyone
could do if if you just tell them how to
do it so right now on my other screen I
guess I could bring this over I'll bring
it over so y'all can see it won't be as
boring so here's a the WordPress site
where we have all our different post
types we're only using WordPress for the
content management alright so this is a
normal WordPress site where we'd go in
and have a theme and all that we just
want the content management it's
basically just a UI for users to be able
to very easily put data into it my
sequel database that's all we're using
it for
majors let's find English well no we're
doing departments aren't we yeah
departments so we're gonna search see
the admin section here with wordpress is
actually pretty nice so you know why
reinvent an admin thing if we could just
use wordpress it's not exactly the way
that it's intended to use wordpress but
it works English department text yeah
this is it this is what we want okay so
we need to go into slug so by default
you don't see slug on WordPress I need
to enable that so now that I've enabled
it I can see the slug so I'm gonna
change that to just English so now that
the slug is just English it should work
so let's go back to our site and I'm
gonna do departments I'm sorry
department singular English no oh you
know what I might need to restart the
server let me try that first I think
yeah I think that was an issue last time
I was working on this
let's see like nah hey we got a
different error that's progress let's
see two lowercase element type two
lowercase it's not a function
all right let's check out our code to
see what's going on our our server
Department of Department lists I'm gonna
take this I don't think this is the
problem but just in case let's take it
out because this was kind of the only
new thing we added in the server that I
wasn't sure about so let's take that out
first
and restart just to be sure if this
works it'll be an easy fix so it's worth
trying out first so let's let that
restart it should only take a second
all right we're still getting the same
error yeah okay and that's fun let me
see I should look at the live chat to
see if anybody noticed all right
but seeing if anybody noticed the
mistake that I had made so where do we
need department pages let's make sure
that I've got I'm guessing that maybe I
didn't copy I didn't change every
instance of major to Department part of
a query department
I wonder maybe
alright harsh is saying test the query
we need
I wonder if I need to refresh where's my
word presence though
oh yeah I didn't know there was some
issue with WordPress that I I needed to
I don't even remember what it was called
I needed a mess like flush the
permalinks I think or something like
that so I just wanted to double-check
that the error should to air in the
component
okay harsh it says Visual Studio code is
showing Aran errors in the component
okay and then missing space before
function for instance all right all
right
the error is it not saved is that the
problem oh I just
Aniki is saying I didn't save it alright
let's let's see if that was the problem
all right
I feel real silly but I'm really glad
that was no that wasn't the problem well
it kind of was it kind of was we have a
different era now so it's saying edges
is undefined okay so that probably means
we're not getting the data back that we
should be getting so go down here saying
edges is undefined so I wonder I'm gonna
change from plural to singular see if
that makes a difference all right
so I don't think that was the case in my
query let me change from floral to
singular here see if it makes a
difference hmm no I know that that fix
something the last time all right sweet
you
I don't think I want this route I don't
know if this is what's messing us up but
I definitely don't want this in here so
I'm gonna comment it out for now just in
case I'd I realized later that I wanted
it in there let's see
so while that refreshes I'm just going
to show you this was taking basically
anything that that was put in here after
a slash and treating it like an ID and
then sending it to the component major
and I did not want that to happen and
that potentially could have been messing
things up all right that's just know
still still problem okay Department
as I am saying Department right
yeah departments and departments at some
sending that to the right place
all right okay let's listen test so a
little earlier harsh it had the good
idea to test the query so let's do that
to where I can never remember how to get
back to there it is haha
and my cursor right on there I just
could never remember what the icon was
okay all right so we are yeah we're at
the right end points and let's run that
okay not work in the schema
that's good that's odd we don't have
anything I wonder if any of our routes
are working let's go to something that
yeah let's go to a faculty members page
oh okay so something's wrong with
everything so it's not just that that
query so what is going on
just check our plugins WP graph QL
yes
and check the version zero zero point
two two
it looks like there's no breaking
changes so at least nothing labeled as a
breaking change so you might want to
just update see if that makes a
difference
my
all right hard should has put in sec -
WP next yearís you know har should has
put in a different URL here yeah that
URL should work hardship but this one
this one's been working for me as well
I'll try out the other one though let's
do that quickly before we go do some
questions actually where we
actually that's what we have been using
let's try to switch that out for for
this and see if it makes a difference
the difference it's just enough
let's see all right well let me go to
work says faculty is is also unsaved oh
it shouldn't I haven't done any work on
faculty I asked for a long time so it
should be fun and we we had it we had it
working
oh yeah let me add to let me take a
break answer some questions maybe this
will help clear my mind a bit as well
alright so we're gonna take five minutes
and scroll all the way up to the top of
the live chat
meelo says I've been following your
previous livestream great videos thank
you I really appreciate you saying that
and thanks for watching
Lucas says hi Jessie I'm from Brazil and
I'm a software developer I like so much
your live streams awesome thank you for
saying that
Adrian asked what the timer was for I
think I did explain at the beginning
I'll just explain it quickly again
it likes it breaks up my work so I use
it throughout the day to break up my
work into small chunks it just makes
things more manageable you make sure you
you get a break and the breaks are nice
because you stop and think you know
sometimes you get into doing something
and it's you keep working at it working
at it if you take time to stop and think
you might find like oh I may have been
doing this I could have done it this way
and it would be so much better or you
know maybe we just deal with something
completely different so it lets you stop
and just think about what the best use
of your time can be but anyway on the
show I on the stream we break it up so
I'd do 25 minutes of coding in five
minutes in the live chat 25 minutes of
coding like back and forth and that way
I don't ignore the live chat for too
long but then also I don't get caught up
and just talking the whole time and not
getting anything done with the code
Glauber s what's the graph QL client you
use so we're using Apollo with our react
app and then on the WordPress
installation we're using a plug-in
called WP graph QL that just gets all
that data out of WordPress for us
without you know we don't really have to
setup very much of anything Christian
says this is open source cool yep
everything I do here is is open source
almost everything there was like one
project we did a little bit of work on
that was a private repo and that beak
says hi everyone hey how's it going
Michael asked if in the link that I
posted are those M's or ours
followed by ends not sure when I click
on that how do you know what would it be
oh I see what you mean now Michael yet
don't want to click on that if it was if
it was the latter case you know hello
how's it going I haven't seen you in the
stream for a while I'm glad glad you
could join us today
it's site site our site re on hopefully
I pronounced that right says Jesse could
you say how much of a challenge it would
be to make an API and node that a
front-end react application could use to
read and write a database hmm I mean I
guess it it somewhat depends on the
details right but making an API like
that it's not it's not really that big
of a deal so I mean it defends like if
you've done it before if you're good
with nodes so there's a lot of different
factors that could make it take longer
but like a very simple node API is is
not really that difficult
Harshit would be a better one to know
exactly because he handles
a lot of back-end stuff he's a harsh it
would you say you're mostly a back-end
developer I mean you're pretty you're
pretty full stack though so but anyway
har should set up a lot more stuff like
that then I have so maybe he could you
know give a better answer best always
says I'm using WordPress also as a
content management data source
awesome awesome yeah it's it's way more
common now I remember like a couple
years ago people were talking about it
but it was like who's really using this
in production and I was very curious
about it because I had been doing
WordPress sites before like the normal
way and so I kind of messed around with
it a little bit and I did end up doing
sites for clients with it when it was
still like kind of new but now I think
it's more like people are aware of it
you know larger sites are using it in
production so it's kind of like
mainstream now I guess but it's still
weird concept for some people like I'm
pretty sure some of my bosses like think
that I'm making a just a regular
WordPress site it's just hard
I guess hard to explain just so hard and
unless you're doing it like you're in
the the process of creating it you know
maybe a little bit difficult to
understand why it's like we're using
WordPress but it's not a wordpress site
right all right my five-minute timer is
up so I'm gonna write down where I left
off here in the live chat and let's
figure out what the problem is here I
think we're really close to getting this
to work
all right so we're not getting any data
from WordPress so let's try this
so we've already tested out both these
URLs but I do want to grab this URL
again and let's go over here where we're
testing this out let me make this a lot
bigger for you all and we can actually
expand that there we are
all right so I'm gonna put in this and
see what happens when we set that
endpoint all right yeah we have server
errors for both and double check seven
point servers all right
so let's let's upgrade then let's
upgrade our or plug in and see if it if
it helps I'd like to upgrade to plug in
anyway so now's a good time to do it if
it fixes our problem great if it doesn't
then at least we've updated our plugin
ok
Harshit says try reverting the changes
in the plugin which which plugin are we
talking about the the custom post types
one
I'm just scanning this plugin quickly
just to see if something stands out as a
mistake all right everything looks okay
just from a quick scan it looks okay
terms of the stuff that I've changed
that's weird was it okay
now I guess we can check where did I
bring that up over here
No all right let's see
all right I'm going to go to WordPress
and let's upload this plugin
let's go to the plugins let's it's
getting rid of this version and its
install the new one alright so now all
we have to do is just upload this zip
file if you guys kilos and will activate
the plug-in wonderful I am going to go
back in here to the permalinks and this
at least it did say in the documentation
for this plug-in maybe it's different
now but at one time it said you had to
flush the permalinks for everything to
work I don't know of any other way to
flush the permalinks other than to do
this I'm sure there's probably some some
other way but this works for me and it
only takes a few seconds all right let's
see what we have now I guess I could
just check right here or right here
mmm
all right let me check out some of this
as inputs earners as photogenic
felicitations
okay check the console I should say
check the console all you mean the dev
tools console
alright let's get rid of this and
refresh okay that's a lot of stuff
500 internal server error
Harshad saying check the console in
graphic QL all her [ __ ] I was just I was
just saying if the schema would come up
I mean I could put a query and I guess
ooh
there's still the same
ma'am well I'd say we've narrowed it
down the problem is something with
WordPress I'm going to check the issues
this doesn't look like the area that
we're getting let's see
all right Nicki's hang a type error
check out workers
let me
I'm gonna comment out a lot of the
custom stuff that I just did today just
in case I've messed something up here
actually I really want to do this am I
gonna lose my data I can't remember if I
lose the data or not all right let me
think
I'm scrolling through the live chat
comments here just to make sure I I'm
trying everything that you're suggesting
No
Harshit says revert plugin
Harshit which plugin the custom one or
the WP graph QL one
I'm gonna wait for clarification here
for just a few seconds the custom one
okay all right
nice right the custom one yeah
if I
okay
editor
it says
this is out I whoops
all right we got something different Oh
obviously that okay so there was some
problem with what I put in the plugin
and now we know that all right so let me
undo that and let's go through so
basically from news on down it was
didn't work so I'm gonna try to narrow
it down as much as we can so news works
let's leave Department type in there and
comment out everything else
all right this is gonna be a little bit
tedious but not too bad all right cool
still working Oh actually okay now let's
undo this one create major
okay cool I should get I want to see if
I get if I take this out if I can still
at least get a schema yeah okay I get
the schema so I should but that all
works all right now let's try this one
Human Resources
all right there we go we got the
internal server error back yes so let's
check out what happened here that's
different okay
the resources
shoes
I'm changing this to camel case just in
case graph QL WP graph K plug-in does
not like the the hyphens
yes all right cool that's the problem we
can't put hyphens my slightly remember
do you remember when the guy who built
the dopey graph QL plug-in was in here I
remember talking about some issue with
these hyphens man why can't I remember
his name though I gotta I gotta give him
credit for this plugin so you gotta
figure out his name he was just here on
this issue
anybody remember Jason that's it
Jason was in here in the live chat a
while back Jason ball yet thanks Nikki
all right cool
so all I have to do now is uncomment
this and hope that I did not like
reading those my data here I don't think
I did but if I did that's a lot of
migration that I have to do over again
all right cool
it's there yeah all right everything's
still there awesome
now let's double check you hey all right
cool now let's go back here I hope I
didn't mess it up while I was trying to
get in everything to work and see what's
happening yeah it works awesome okay
let's go back yeah hey English
department nice we've got the text here
for the English department Suites ha ha
all right that was cool just got a
comment things out and you find the
problem awesome all right this
definitely needs a title let's let's add
that title in in our react component
saintly self sometimes yes almost three
minutes let's do this
you in here with h2 and was
and I don't need double curlies
all right let's see if I did that right
I typed consonant let's title no I don't
want English department text no gotta be
kidding me
ha
cool my coworker got me a burrito for
lunch and I was streaming instead of
eating it so thank you I appreciate it
all right let's see what am I looking
for all the wordpress thing I want to
see the part where I'm at departments
English department text
I want to bring in hi this is where it's
actually gonna be really useful that I
brought in the slug oops
because now I'm gonna do slug
this should give us in English and then
all we need to do is change the padding
on that and make it uppercase and we can
add Department in at the end right so
you can go like in English can I do this
let's sure if I can do that let's see oh
cool I can um yeah so we'll just clean
that up a bit and then basically that's
it that's all we need now this isn't
really a lot of content there's some
other stuff pieces of data that I could
pull in so I don't know if you noticed
here like we have a program list the
header is really specific to the the old
content management system so we'll
probably get rid of that I'm gonna have
somebody else I think come in here and
clean all this up and just leave what we
need we have some this slider we're not
gonna need because it won't work with
the new system I'm not sure if the links
will work so potentially we could add in
a few other things on that page but for
right now at least we have a URL that
matches up with the URL on the current
site and we have some content some
relevant content there that's all we
need for launch we can always add things
later on I'd rather have things be super
fast and really clean clean-looking may
be risking being like bear or too plain
then try to add in a bunch of stuff not
make our launch date and have things
loading slow
all right so my timer went off again let
me go back to the live chat I'm gonna
pick up right where I left off I'm gonna
go through I'm gonna answer all your
questions I'll read out some comments
too if you have any questions now please
put them in the live chat if you're
watching this recording later and you
have a question please put it in the
comments or you can talk to me on
Twitter or Instagram or whatever
Facebook however you want to find me I'm
pretty easy to find on the Internet all
right let's now I'm getting hungry now
that I know there's a burrito waiting
for me all right cool
also I talked yesterday a little bit
about mental health and I just wanted to
give you another little update so I
don't know something you might be bored
when I talk about stuff like this but I
know so many of you told me that you you
struggle with mental health issues like
depression anxiety as well so I thought
I'd just bring this up so this morning I
was up super early like 4 a.m. and I got
up worked out I work out on like an
exercise bike so I played some Zelda on
the Nintendo switch and checked my my
Twitter you know my Instagram and all
that I even did some weights I have a
little weight bench in the basement so I
haven't done like free weights and
probably since summer like early summer
because I hurt my wrist I was kind of
afraid to mess it up but if I keep it
really straight you know put the weight
in the right spot it doesn't hurt my
wrist so that's good to know
anyway I did all that I felt really good
when I went to sleep last night it was
like I could stay up and you know do
what watch Netflix or something or I
could go to bed early and I was excited
to wake up in the morning early
like that never happens for me usually
I'm feeling down I get to the end of the
night and it's like I can't sleep I want
to stay up because for some reason and I
feel like worthless like I didn't get
anything done that day and so it's
somehow like extending the day will make
it better but it never does it just
makes me like look at the clock and say
like ah tomorrow's gonna be terrible cuz
I'm have to wake up and I'm gonna no
sleep it's like this cycle right but now
with the help of some melatonin and I
can go to sleep early and then my body
naturally wakes me up my alarm was set
for 6:00 I woke up at 4:00 and I felt
great
I got like seven hours like seven and a
half hours of sleep I was in bed early
sorry I had my feet up on something and
they just fell off so that was why I
just jerk so so anyway I just kind of
wanted to share that I'm sure that's not
a solution for everybody we're all
different but it's working for me so far
this has been almost two weeks that I've
been doing this and like my body finally
got a routine where it's starting to
happen like naturally and I feel good I
start to feel tired a lot earlier in the
day but you know that's okay when I need
to be awake for work and then you know I
come play with my kids for a little bit
I have enough energy so anyway I just
wanted to share that all right I'm gonna
go back to the live chat now and as
always let me know your opinion on stuff
if you want me to share more or less or
the same amount of this kind of stuff
please let me know I'll try to wait till
the end to share it then that way if you
just are here for the code you can take
off but anyway I always want to make the
streams better so I do appreciate
feedback Christian says why don't use
Keystone Jas we actually thought about
using Keystone we read up on that
it's just Keystone I believe Keystone
was the one that looked really promising
but it hadn't been updated for a long
time it just seemed like it wasn't
really that
we maintain so I was nervous about using
something that might not be maintained
that's why we end up not going with
Keystone and we looked at some other
things like Keystone but everything was
like in Vedas though I just I didn't
want to use it for this site
Jake asks if this is a project for a
client well it's for my employer so I do
have some clients on the side that I do
work for but this particular site is for
my employer which is Franciscan
University
so I'm employed here in the marketing
department as a front-end developer and
this is their gonna be their main
website so it's a big deal it's the
biggest project that I've worked on for
them a lot of people are I wouldn't say
a lot of people but the people that know
what I'm doing are like kind of excited
what's it Scott which is cool they
they've seen my other work and so
they're I think they have high
expectations for this so I don't want to
let anybody down mainly their
expectations are it's gonna be clean and
it's gonna be really fast and it's going
to be easy to navigate from from the
people I've talked to that's like the
things that they're expecting from this
so that's what I want to deliver Jake
also asks did they request Reax seems a
bit overkill for a university website
unless I'm missing something which I
probably am that's a really good
question I think we addressed some of
this earlier maybe not with this project
but with some previous projects that I
thought I tended to agree possibly did
not need reacts but here's my feeling on
that number one all the projects that I
do here tend to grow there's like so
much scope creep and since this isn't my
client that I can just walk away from
when our contract is over I'm still here
I'm always here I'm gonna have to
maintain what I build so projects like
this I've done before here in like just
playing JavaScript jQuery and stuff and
then as the additions pile up it gets to
be a mess we saw two days ago I showed
everyone the example of my my spaghetti
code jQuery single page app that is just
it's hard to maintain
so when was something like react which
has these components and a structure
makes it a lot easier to maintain in my
opinion also by doing react we're kind
of go and react all across the board
unless we're doing something really
simple we're using react my my colleague
that works next to me is using WordPress
with with themes as well so he has like
a custom theme that works with our
branding so if we need a like a single
page site or something up really quickly
he could just use that theme and he has
it all on like a subdomains that he
could just pop up another page in that
WordPress installation so we do use that
for some small things but ultimately by
using reacts with everything we can have
this wealth of components and code that
can be easily copied and pasted in a
project so you kind of see the
progression that we just kind of roll
over the same code into the next project
reuse a lot so it's like immediately we
go into a project and we have so much
done already so it's kind of nice to do
it like that also I would like to get
better with react I would like our
students here in the computer science
department to get better with react
because it's it's in such high demand so
I do have some interns well I have at
least one intern work that's gonna work
with me this semester and then I have
some other students that are gonna do
maybe some projects for a class so not
officially an internship so anyway I
thought hey I I can choose whatever I
want to use for this why not choose
something that's going to help out in a
lot of different ways
I also figure if we end up hiring like
let's say my department grew most likely
I would turn into maybe somewhat like of
a project manager and I would have or
maybe a lead developer or something and
out of people working under me it's I
think much more attractive if I go at a
job to put out a Job Description to say
hey like come work with
react graph QL just the latest like we
want to stay on top of things versus hey
let's work with this old Ektron CMS
and some jQuery like that's that's good
and then I'm gonna have to put like I
need somebody that knows asp.net and
sequel server and my sequel and PHP in
c-sharp and right so I'm basically going
to say like I want a full stack
developer than those multiple languages
but I'm gonna pay you as much as I don't
know like I don't even know what the
salary like and I don't want to say an
intern because anyway we're a small
university so we can't compete on salary
with with most companies that are hiring
developers so I'm trying to look ahead
to the future and say at one place we
can compete is if we can guarantee
developers that we are open to using the
latest technology so that at least if
you're not making the money you want now
you come here build up your skills work
up some projects then you'll be in a
position to get hired and make more
money if you want those are my thoughts
hopefully it makes a little bit more
sense as to why I went with react I do
agree that for this site based on what
we're doing now with the site not 100%
necessary to use react we could have
just used straight WordPress and it
would have worked it would definitely
not have been as fast as what we're
doing or I think as as versatile
WordPress can be really versatile but I
love being able to have complete control
over things full-stack Java scripts I
mean albeit there's some PHP going on in
the background you know with WordPress
but basically our routing and everything
we're doing javascript so also the odds
of this site staying like it is and not
having additional things built into it
that it would be nice to have react for
a really
like this is nothing ever just stays as
is somebody always has an idea it was
like can we do this so it's nice that I
can say like sure we can do that and I
know I don't know exactly how to do it
with react would be easier than let's
say with with WordPress I have
experience with WordPress but I just
hate to keep like add new plugins all
the time and my PHP is not good enough
to custom code it and I don't really
want to learn that much more PHP anyway
that went off in a big tangent on that
but I haven't really spoke about that
for a long time like I'm banging months
so failure is a good good time to
explain my reasoning behind that all
right I see there were a lot of
suggestions that you all gave on trying
to find that error I really appreciate
that world says maybe you broke the
Internet
hey we got that WP graft UL plug-in
upgraded to that was a nice little bonus
I didn't I didn't plan on doing that
today but it seemed like nothing broke
it all works Alexi says hey everybody
hey Lexi thanks for joining us
yes Stephen said maybe you need some
coffee
you see Nikki and Michael Oher making
some IT jokes and stuff throughout here
so it makes no sense now I glanced over
and just saw these like random comments
like what are they talking about
her [ __ ] noticed how happy I was when I
got the air it's yeah I was so hot
because then we found it right like we
were trying to find what piece of code
made the error so anyway sometimes like
getting a different error is also really
exciting because you know you did
something right like you made some
progress a different error
Arshad asked if sitemaps help in SEO
yeah I would definitely do a sitemap SEO
is it's difficult to say exactly how
much something helps an SEO mainly
because search engines usually don't
tell you their formula if you knew their
formula it would be really easy to like
play the system right like people use
this stuff their meta tags was thought
you know like their site would be about
I don't know like skateboards right they
sell skateboards but they would stuff
their meta tags with like everything
that was really interesting that that
was the top search terms so now like
meta tags are basically worthless so
when the meta keywords tag is like
worthless now so anyway that being said
I think it's still good practice to have
a sitemap I haven't really been into SEO
for a while I used to be really
knowledgeable about SEO like that was
one of the things that I promise why you
can never promise right but one of the
things that I would tell clients is that
you know I'm going to try to get you on
the front page of Google search results
and I was I was successful I could with
their main search terms I could get
every company that I ever tried with on
the first page of Google they were all
local businesses though which is in my
opinion it's not that hard to get a
small local business up higher in their
area like in a limited geographic area
nationally or globally ranking
somebody's that's the real trick anyway
sitemaps helped as far as I know
let's see Oh Christian says what was the
bug okay Christian the specific bug was
I was using so in graph QL I had this
hyphenated side campus - security and
you can't use hyphens when I give a
graph QL named for these things you have
to use camel case or all lowercase you
know something like that that was the
issue so that that was the bug among
other things like the first bug we had
was I forgot to save the file
the next bug we had was I don't even
remember I think we had some like
intermediary bug between them but then
finally the ultimate problem was that
that I wasn't supposed to have a hyphen
there and now I may have to go in and
change some queries well you know what I
didn't even make queries for these yet
so I don't have to change anything I'll
just have to remember when I do these
queries the camel cases the world says
burritos are good for mental health - I
would agree with that I'm not a doctor
so don't don't take that as medical
advice Wow
Martin said I slept well I select 19
hours two days ago it was bad 19 hours
that's a lot of sleep I can't I couldn't
get 19 hours I have too many kids for
that somebody would wake me up for sure
I'm lucky if I can get like just a
regular night's sleep like seven hours
without some kid waking up and needing
something
enjoy sleep while you can if you don't
have kids I love them though I wouldn't
trade it for sleep alright so Nicky says
the updates like the mental health
updates are great interesting two topic
that is often avoided all right cool
I won't talk about it every day but I'll
bring it up you know occasionally world
says its Franciscan University named
after the current Pope Francis no it's
named after Saint Francis from 12th or
13th 1913 century so yes so I think it
was st. Francis was you know he was
around Italy in that general area in the
13th century so he did a lot of really
cool stuff if you check out check out
his story it's pretty good really
wealthy gave up everything he once went
visited a Muslim Sultan and talked to
him about Catholicism like really just
kind of exciting cool stuff happened
yeah and so anyway he started a
religious order that eventually became
known as the Franciscans it's really the
FRA order of Friars Minor is the
official name he didn't name it after
himself but now we just call them the
Franciscans for short so that's why so
the university is run by members of the
order of Friars Minor who are like
spiritual descendants of st. Francis
so this university has been around since
the 40s or 50s
I think 50s so definitely predates the
current Pope but anyway a good question
thanks Michael says definitely share
more about your depression slash anxiety
I'm going
to the site for one psychologist or
psychiatrist and taking medicine for the
other haven't tried melatonin because of
the depression sleep isn't a problem for
me yeah yeah it's kind of weird right
like so for me at least what I'm feeling
depressed like I just want to sleep but
then if I stay up to a certain point
like I won't sleep right it's like in
the morning I don't want to get out of
bed but at night I feel so depressed and
feeling like I wasted a day I just don't
want to sleep it's weird
it's kind of like a weird point for me
there so that's why the melatonin is
easy like you
it doesn't I've taken the sleeping pills
before that are like you know medical
stuff that you can get addicted to and
those work I feel groggy they're like
the sleep I get with those I don't
really like as much there was one thing
I had though that was prescription and
that was amazing
but melatonin is nice it just helps you
get to sleep I feel okay the next
morning and it's non-habit-forming so
like I said again I'm not a doctor so
don't don't listen to anything I'm
saying you know as good medical advice
but melatonin is pretty safe at least
from what I have my experience
let's see michael says scope creep
yeah scope creep like so like you have
your initial like requirements for your
project and then as your project goes on
the client will add on extra things like
oh can we make it do that can we make it
do that and then you have scope creep so
the project scope weather climbers the
project all of a sudden get bigger when
I'm working here it's okay like I still
get paid no matter what but for a client
it can be problematic because you have
your contract set out and if it's a flat
rate for let's say like I'm gonna make
your website I'm going to charge you ten
thousand dollars and it's going to do
this and then the clients are saying
well I wanted to do this
this at that point you need to say
that's outside the scope of our initial
agreement if you want to do that we're
either gonna have to amend our first
contract or we're gonna have to bring
you know make a new contract and
sometimes like I've had to say that
before the clients and sometimes the
client says okay well that's outside of
our budget sometimes they say all right
let's let's amend it other times I've
had clients that compromise it okay well
this is how much more we can spend what
can we get for that and so we don't add
all the features we just kind of
prioritize like all right we'll do this
and then maybe later on if you have the
money like come back we'll add the other
features so that's let's weigh me my
scope creep
so I said for me it's not a problem but
since I'm gonna have to maintain it I
just have to kind of say like okay how
can I build this project knowing that
we'll probably have new features added
later on so I just try to build it from
the outset in a way that'll be easy to
add things on to Martinus our react
angular and view roughly equally easy to
scale and maintain to be honest I can't
really answer that because I I don't
have much experience with angular or
view from what I know though from what
other devs say from what I've heard
they're all they're all pretty easy like
they're all nice frameworks they all
scale they're all you know somewhat easy
to maintain but it does depend on how
you build it right you can use react
angular of you and make a site that's
terrible and a mess or you can you know
you can use vanilla JavaScript to make
something amazing so it does depend on
you know how you build them but I can't
really give you like you know something
from my experience for angular review
though
oh okay I didn't I didn't notice that
Nikki already gave you an answer to the
scope Creek thing Michael so sorry for
the double answer there
Oh world says that makes sense I think
the current Pope is named after Saint
Francis - yep yep that is that's where
he took his name from which was unique
he's the first pope to take the name
Francis
let's see Michael says please minimize
that dev tools window it's kind of hard
to concentrate on you
Oh was i use the dev tools huge sorry
Ghana says react with a heart yeah for
sure we love react on this this dream I
don't say that as in to put down any
other frameworks I think you know
everything has its place and can be
useful different situations but lately
we found react to be a very good tool
for for what we're doing
Umberto's says I think I've slept 19
hours since Monday VFX says is C or Java
better for a career-making language in
the field Mandela says c-sharp and Java
are good in the USA vivec says I think I
have to switch to Java Umberto says
which which field for web I would say
she's sharp graphics and gaming it's a
toss-up between C and C sharp with unity
Vivek says I'm in university but I want
to make a career in AI so artificial
intelligence imperative says for AI
Python and C / C++ for robotics VFX says
yes I'm learning Python but Java is
currently in my course Humberto says job
is good
foundation for learning object-oriented
programming really good for establishing
principles and patterns and coding in my
opinion let's see so once that's to see
Vivek I pretty much agree with Umberto's
assessment there as well in terms of
what what languages to use like I mean
basically you can do you can do a lot in
pretty much any language but there are
certain languages that seem to be used
more with with other things like if
you're gonna do anything on the web you
probably need to learn some JavaScript
it seems like yeah Python is really big
and like machine learning AI stuff now
so yeah I guess it just really all
depends on what you want to do and
whether you like it's you don't have to
do Python if you want to get into
machine learning or AI like you can do
another languages it I mean the odds of
maybe finding like a company that's into
that that's using the language you like
might be smaller but if you learn one
language well it's not too as difficult
to switch to another language so I
wouldn't worry too much about what
language you're learning because you
can't always switch you know I wouldn't
say it's like entirely easy to switch
but it's a lot easier if you have the
basic principles down Brook says what is
the lorem ipsum text actually about all
that and I got in high school is long
gone here um well this lorem ipsum text
is bacon ipsum so it's sprinkled in with
names of different meats so this
probably means nothing I can't remember
what normal lorem ipsum is it's a
passage from I believe like classic work
of literature
I can't remember which so yeah I can't
remember which so I did teach Latin but
that was years ago and I taught
ecclesiastical latin so like i can tell
you a lot of like so let's say like
latin poems and prayers written in the
Middle Ages or certain like passages
from let's say from like the the Latin
Vulgate which is like the Latin
translation of the Bible made in like
like 5th century 4th century somewhere
around there so when it comes to reading
classical Latin literature like we're
talking like Roman Empire stuff I I'm
not I don't really feel at all qualified
to do that kind of thing Chris asks why
do those seals prefer those particular
languages to be honest with you Chris
I'm not really sure I don't know if
there's anything intrinsic to those
languages that make them better suited
to that or not or it just so happened
that the kind of the pioneers in those
fields use those languages so there's
kind of more of an ecosystem built up
around them I I don't really know
Umberto says I believe it's because they
were either created specifically for
certain platforms or because they work
better to tackle problems in in those
fields Vivek says I want a career in AI
and machine learning but C and Java and
my course and currently I'm learning
algorithms so I'm confused that I
continue with Java C yet yet it's sorry
if I'm mispronouncing that let me know
how I should pronounce it so that I'm
planning to make a recommendation system
using machine learning and I think
Python is the only way what do you think
about it have you ever done something
similar I haven't done anything with
machine learning
yet I think it's awesome and I'd love to
get into it but I'd have to think of
some way probably to work it into my
current job and then maybe I could
really learn it yeah so I can't say much
about it
I think Python is fine it's a good
language I I liked it when I the very
little that I've ever done with Python I
I liked it and I've heard from a lot of
a lot of different sources that Python
is the way to go although you can do
machine learning and other languages so
you know you're not tied down the Python
if you really don't want to use it
okay Umberto says like C C++ allows more
granular control over memory management
okay cool that's that's a good example I
really couldn't think of an example but
that's an example of how one language
might have be good at something and that
would matter for a particular
application
best Allah says good points on react
I've heard many times it's overkill
haven't used it myself so far do you
think is really so requested I see a lot
of jobs for react now maybe I'm seeing
those jobs because on Stack Overflow
they know that I'm into react and so
they show me react jobs it could be that
but I've I've seen in other places that
is say like react it jobs are in really
high demand right now
so I figure why not do that and the fact
that react so versatile I think is is a
plus as well so some of the sites that
we've done before that didn't really
need react it was good that we did it
with react because now we're converting
them to desktop apps and to mobile apps
which means we can use react native and
it makes it a lot easier to just like
port something over to some o
and then there's also other things you
can do with react like you know there
are people doing VR stuff and reacts try
think what else was that what else you
for doing I don't know I saw a list
before of all the things that weird
things that people would only react and
it was it was long there's a lot of
stuff so it does have advantages like
beyond just what it can do on the web
Borna says what framework will be best
in five years time if we don't look at
the ones that will come I don't know I
mean I have no idea how to how to answer
that I mean in five years probably all
the same languages will still be around
maybe will have will have a new one I I
don't really know yeah who could know I
don't know anything give a cast about
and what's my opinion about Java or C I
I don't know I've used both very
minimally like I'm talking like hello
world type stuff so I don't think I know
enough to really have a qualified
opinion about either one
I'll tell you what it regarded the
question about what will be the best
what framework will be the best in five
years I'm sorry I misread that question
I think I'm inserted at first about what
language what framework yeah I'm in five
years I think we'll probably have a new
framework but there's going to be react
stuff around just because of an angular
because they're companies that invested
a lot of money is switching over to that
and they're not going to be really happy
to completely switch again anytime soon
I hope that react is still around and
one of the best because if I I'm trying
to learn react well and then it'll be
good for me
but if it's another one you know I just
learned the other one that's that's kind
of that's how this business works
let's see yet
yeah dude says thanks I have a
non-coding question what PC do you have
and were there any projects where you
actually needed a really powerful PC I'm
actually on an iMac right now so my mic
has 32 gigs of ram I think I upgraded to
32 I don't really know what the other
specs on it are but I've never had a
problem the only issue I've ever had
with this is sometimes I've dropped some
frames if I've had some really like kind
of heavy things running but in my actual
work like I'm talking about the live
stream I dropped some frames so with my
actual work I've never had an issue
trying to livestream and work at the
same time I have that an issue I do have
a PC at home but I haven't used it in so
long I can't even remember what the
specs are on it I have a MacBook Pro
that I mostly use at home and with that
I I tell you I don't really know what
the specs are are they so sorry I really
I should know more but I used to be in
there like building and like modifying
computers and stuff but lately it's
harder it's a lot harder to do with Macs
anyway and I just haven't had a lot of
free time to mess around with it at home
so nor have i really had the need to the
need was mostly like how do I make my
computer run games better but I don't
really have a lot of time for like PC
games lately defect says what type of
coding do you do live it's JavaScript
mostly JavaScript usually with the react
library defect says what it would is
react or angular they're there a way
that you can structure your JavaScript
to make applications so yeah I guess
that's kind of like the most generic way
to to answer that that question usually
they're made for like single page
applications progressive web apps like
things like that green coder says cloud
9 is amazing
yeah cloud 9 is really cool I do like
cloud 9 cloud 9 is like a like a cloud
development environment where you
basically have like you're like
connected to your own Linux machine like
but in the cloud so you could use it
from anywhere it's really good like if
you run a Chromebook then cloud 9 is the
way to go if you want to develop things
on a Chromebook Borna says what do you
think about blockchain technology Green
says tired of hearing about blockchain
yeah honestly I think blockchain is
gonna change a lot of things I think all
the hyper on blockchain right now
misses the point like the stuff in
mainstream media that blockchain like
obviously I have money and some
cryptocurrency right like what why not
you know not a lot just a little bit and
that's cool all the speculation and the
price fluctuations like it stuffs fun
but that's not really good blockchain is
all about I think the the idea of have
different systems and right now are
either controlled by governments or
corporations now be trustworthy without
having anyone in control that's like a
game-changer when we see like let's say
a country's currency gets destabilized
and then all of a sudden like their main
method of buying and selling things
becomes some form of cryptocurrency
like that's a game-changer right now all
of a sudden like that government has no
control over monetary policy you know
they're they're out of the currency
business like how is that going to work
to change things
how would that then affect like the
imports and exports for that country
tourism for that country it is just so
many things that are different that are
gonna change the same way with like
social media you could have social media
networks that are distributed on
blockchain and now one company doesn't
decide how things work on their same way
for messaging right a government can't
go to a company now and demand that they
have all the records of whatever
somebody said because there is no one to
go to and so you see there's a lot of
stuff and that's you know there's a lot
of other implications for that that I
think will be like as time goes on
it could potentially change
communications and economics like
financial systems quite a bit I'm not an
expert on blockchain I've just done a
little reading on it Borna says
absolutely I agree
Green coder says how many hours do you
code usually on my streamer in a day on
my stream i usually code for like an
hour and then do question and answers
session during a day it does kind of
depend on like how many meetings I have
and what I'm working on but I would say
average if you count my coding on the
stream - maybe like like four out of the
seven hours that I'm here I definitely
code some days I do more other days
especially if I have meetings I do less
so I work like a seven hour day so it's
like eight hours but with an hour for
lunch
so within that time period I'd say I'm
like for sure coding other time is
filled up with like talking to my boss
talk like catching up on emails and
different things like that maybe like
reading about frameworks like
documentation and things so during work
now if I have a project on the side at
home I could be coding for a lot longer
than that
Vivek says is there any relation between
Java and JavaScript Java and JavaScript
have the same relation as ham and
hamster do they just share a similar
sounding name and that's it that's it I
mean they're both they're both coding
languages but that's it
they're both programming languages vivek
says you have your own company or you're
doing a job I like kind of have my own
side company that I don't do much with
at all so Jesse why go digital marketing
is my like kind of like media company
but I don't advertise this at all I've
left the website up but I don't I don't
do much I have some clients but really
minimal work right now
and then I work for a university so I'm
a friend and developer full-time and
University approve us as how to make
sure about security for remote work let
me know software app for remote work and
safety measures it just kind of depends
for remote stuff like what what type of
stuff you're doing you're working on
yeah I would say I mean it does it just
really depends
honestly I found though the clients are
usually way too trusting like I have
access to way too much stuff from
clients and I just I worry because I'm
thinking like if if they do business
with somebody who doesn't really have
that much of a conscience they're going
to be in trouble
generally it I would think like larger
companies might I would hope have things
better security measures in place but
like small business clients they have no
idea like you they give you access to
everything that they have because they
just don't know they don't know what
anything does you just say all right I
need passwords and they give you
everything plain text over email just
here it is so usually I ask permission
and sometimes get it to change all the
passwords at least to something a little
bit more secure than normally it's like
the name of the business is the passport
so yeah but I don't know that I don't
know how great of an answer that is but
that's been my experience with like
remote freelance work
best alwa says I have the same can't
wake up feeling in the morning
and then a night can't get to sleep yeah
it's crazy
there's crazy a little earth Winkle says
what's the best way to learn about
reacts there are some free resources on
code Academy and a lot of free like
YouTube video resources the react
documentation is pretty good as well if
you want to pay for a course react as or
Udacity has a react nano degree that I
did that I liked so that would be my
suggestions vivek says how do you earn
money well I mean I get a salary from my
main job and then you know from my
freelancing work I get some money on the
side they really minimal world says do
you use agile at your work is a useful I
do something called agile for one so
it's not exactly agile but it uses some
of the techniques from agile I find it
to be very useful but it's not you can't
really do like agile with one person
like exactly the same way Albert says
any senior developers here interested in
building a website for 50% equity of the
company I am NOT I don't have the time
to do anything right now
um maybe after I finished this project
though some time freed up Nicki said
it's got to go thanks for the stream bye
everyone hate see you later thanks for
watching all right got some more
questions I'm going to say a few more
questions I'm after wrap things things
up defects says okay now a non-technical
question how many desktops you have for
coding and also you play PC games I in
three screens three monitors my main
monitor is like a 27-inch I think
27-inch
five K screen my secondary is the same
size mr 2kay and then my third screen is
just like a rake like read a lower res
screen but I have it tilted on its side
so it's like you know going up and down
I used to use four screens when I had my
did most of my work at home I I really
like that I wish it I still at four
bornus is how much is paid coarser boot
camp or the Udacity paid course was for
I think $400
Rick Adams has created a repo with a
roadmap of resources to learn Java PHP
react sequel cool that's really cool
thanks for for letting us know Rick see
world says that burrito is probably
frozen oh yeah I'm gonna have to warm it
up a poor v''e says I know mean sack how
useful is react how much time won't
learn to take I don't know it I don't
really know it really depends everybody
learns at a different rate so I mean if
you're pretty pretty good with
JavaScript you know you could probably
pick up react you know pretty really
quickly if you can spend the time on it
so I don't really want to put a
timeframe on it cuz it's just so many
factors to take into account all right
I'm gonna go now because I am really
hungry and I have food waiting and we're
over the two-hour mark now for the
stream so thank you all so much if you
have any more questions join me next
week in some live streams or message me
some other way thank you all so much for
watching for all your help
definitely like to have the help when we
had to do all our debugging and thanks
you know all the comments and questions
everything I love it so I'll be back
next week and until then have a great
weekend